how do you help clients who are hyper
focused on other people's achievements
i help them get reacquainted with what
their true
dream is i think it's so easy to look at
what everybody else is doing
and to decide that that's what success
means
and so that's what i should go after but
we really want to reconnect with what
our true dream is like what is it that
we
truly want like to tur tune out the
noise stop looking at what other people
are doing stop
looking at social media what people are
doing on social media what they're
posting
and really reconnect to what is it that
you
truly want you know i have this line in
my book that i was actually really proud
of i think it's a good line where i said
when you are trying to replicate someone
else's magic
you are taking yourself out of the
running for your own
and i i think that's so important i
think that as long as you are chasing
somebody else's dream or you're trying
to
you know have or do what other people
are having and doing
you are cutting yourself off from your
own fulfilling
really cool journey you know really
amazing magical experience
you know it's going to be so much more
fulfilling if you reconnect to what it
is that
you want and go after it in a way that
feels good to
you as opposed to comparing yourself to
everybody else and trying to replicate
what other people are doing i think as
long as you are trying to replicate
somebody else's path
you're going to get stuck i i think we
all
have our own path and we we need to find
our own path especially in an industry
like
hollywood where there's no one way to do
anything
you know if you lined up ten successful
people or a hundred successful people
and ask them how did you break in or how
did you get to where you
are you're probably going to hear a
hundred different stories
so it's important that we leave room for
us to find our own story
and that comes from really letting go
and disconnecting from
what you see everybody else doing
what's your definition of a high
achiever
i that's such a good question um because
i use that term all the time
um my definition of a high achiever is
somebody
who first of all has a desire for
something beyond
like the base level you know
like people say oh i want to be a
working actor
and i'm like really like that's such a
base level thing i understand you want
to pay your bills from acting and sure
that would be amazing but
like that's one aren't you you're gonna
want so many more things you know beyond
that
so i think like number one it's about
the desire the desire for something
greater than
what's comfortable for most people and
then i think that
you know a lot of my work in terms of
helping people become high achievers is
about
how you think about what you're doing
what your belief system is behind what
you are doing
so that it leads to higher level risks
higher level actions and strategies that
then
usually lead to higher level
opportunities but so you know in my book
i talk about the 10 pillars of the high
achiever and it's
it's really about how you view what is
possible
and um
[Music]
how you view what you're capable of you
know what you're able to do
so if you're a high achiever you view
the world
in a way that you believe that
anything's possible
and you make decisions based on your
desires and based on your dreams instead
of based on fear
you know you do things that are not
based on those hollywood rules
you know you really go beyond what i
call like the most people pool so you're
not doing what most people
are doing um you're doing what the
smaller pool of high achievers are doing
which is you know you're really
you're really looking at the world in a
different way and
and your own dreams in a different way
like if you have a dream of winning an
oscar or
being a millionaire you believe
that not only that it's possible but
that it will happen for you
and just that belief changes that it
changes the entire trajectory
you know of what what potential you have
in front of you
so base level let's say filmmaker
screenwriter
what would that would be they want to
work on a few projects
not they're looking to no i mean like
maybe my working actor example wasn't
the greatest because i'm definitely not
trying to judge anybody's like level but
i think that
you know like beyond student films
beyond unscripted you know if we're
talking about hollywood
for for screenwriters or for any other
kind of craft you know i think that
um beyond what most people strive for
you know because i think that striving
for like a base level
keeps people safe you know i i think
that most people that
have dreams of succeeding in hollywood
in this industry
they have their dreams are beyond
student films or their dreams are beyond
you know just paying their bills
you know i think a lot of people dream
of telling really interesting stories
you know i think people love
storytelling and the art of storytelling
you know a lot of the people that i work
with they want to make an
impact on people's lives they want to
make a difference in the world through
storytelling
you know i think that that goes beyond i
just want to be able to pay all my bills
from my craft i think everybody wants to
be able to pay all the you know bills
from their craft but
um i think the high achievers they want
more they want to they want to go beyond
that they don't want to stay safe and
comfortable
at whatever level is safe and
what are some of the um achilles heels
of a high achiever
um interesting question um
one of the things that i personally have
struggled with and i consider myself a
high achiever
is all like the fact that i'm
kind of always reaching for something
right and so i think that that might be
an achilles heel of the high achiever
where that bar is always moving and and
so that
like one thing that i've been working on
is being more present
you know being more present in where i
am and
trying to enjoy the moment
because my eyes are usually always on
the next thing
you know i'm always reaching i'm always
on that next thing i always want to know
my next goal
you know right now i'm in this period
where i don't really know for sure
what that next goal is for me and i've
never
experienced that before it's very
uncomfortable
to have to just sit here and be present
and wait for it to
sort of come or be inspired
um and so i think that's probably a high
achiever's achilles heels that
you know they're not really sometimes
struggling with being present and
enjoying the journey and enjoying where
they are because their eyes are always
on the next
thing is there no other way around that
as a high achiever is that just part of
the journey so to speak yeah i mean
i don't i don't want to put my own
struggles on anybody else and make a
blanket statement and say that you know
all high achievers will you know
struggle with that i think everybody
we all have our own stuff you know um
so yeah i i think you know everyone's
going to have their own struggles but
it's really about
how willing are you to do the work
to better yourself and to get where you
want to go
you